former irish prime minister bertie ahern
welcome very much to sky news how will
you remember him
well i negotiated with him probably for
10 years and
he was a formidable negotiator he was um
a tough guy could be uncompromising on
what he believed in
but the important thing was that
whenever he agreed something whenever
uh we
settled on whatever the project was but
it was on the road into the good friday
agreement are the many years after
when both tony blair and i were um
negotiating he stopped by his word and
even though he was under horrendous
pressure within his party from other
unionists
some of the wider public and he stuck to
his gun so and i got very friendly with
him over that 10 years obviously he
started from a position where we
differed a lot but
and i've remained friendly with him so
you know a great admiration from his
wife daphne who was very close to
politically and very involved with him
politically
and the family i send my sympathies
there to him
i mean he was central wasn't he to a
defining moment in northern ireland's
recent history being one of the
principal architects of the good friday
agreement i mean can you give us a sense
of what he had to overcome in order to
steer his party to agree to the peace
process well a large part of his party
and didn't really want to be in the
negotiations at all and
then we had agreed on a set of a
comprehensive set of negotiations that
covered um very difficult issues for him
the release of prisoners within two
years unlicensed
the reform of the right of circumstance
into a new police force and the changing
of the um the the laws on equality and
criminal justice and so it was a very um
wide scale
you know spread of legendary
issues many of those
were not issues that were seen by his
party or by the unionist people as being
a good idea
but he saw the bigger picture and the
bigger picture was that we already
continued on with the violence that had
gone on for 30 years or we went on the
road of peace and gave the good friday
agreement a chance of course there were
difficulties about the politics of that
but the important thing was to end the
bloodshed and the mayhem and all the the
bombings and the shootings and um he he
took that decision and it was a brave
decision
yeah i mean many went on to regard him
as a traitor because of what he did i
mean you described him as being
courageous what do you mean by that
well you know when you have a sizable
amount of your party uh that are against
you or when you have a sizable amount of
your party that um are
walking out of the talks i mean you keep
people watch out at the talks on the
very day that we were doing the
negotiations um and then afterwards and
he
not from his own party alone but from
the wider unionist community they
hounded him so much that he ultimately
lost his seat in upper ban um in 2005.
so you know he he had to go through that
period to 95 to 2005 and and to say that
listen for the better good i believe
that
the peace process is the right thing to
do and the violence uh try to make as
much progress as we can on the political
agenda which he did he achieved many
many things on the political agenda but
that wasn't easy when you're getting a
really really tough and you know
orchestrated campaign against them
and you both have shared moments of
history together what's been your most
memorable what's your most favorite
memory of him would you say
well i i suppose you know
when the referendum result was out it
was not at all clear what would happen
in that referendum result i suppose it
was a a risky strategy to put um the
good friday agreement to the people a
month after we negotiated it
and when that came out you know 71
percent uh for the agreement that was a
huge success for all of us but was a
huge success for him because i think he
had taken um the line share of the abuse
from from many people a lot of unionist
people were against it so that that i
think was a huge moment of of pleasure
for him and satisfaction for him and
then to see
that in his lifetime
that the effectively political violence
ended in the north thankfully there's
been very little of it in in the last 25
years yeah i know one former member of
the ulster unionist party has been
talking to uh ireland correspondent
david blevins saying that
his actions mean that there are people
who are alive today that would have died
if not for his work in the peace process
would you agree with that i would agree
with that i mean we were losing um at
least 100 people a year so
and that was a constant and so if you if
you were to follow that suddenly you're
talking about a few thousand people
and not to mind that the huge amount of
people that would have been injured and
named and you know the devastation of
property and you know to family life and
all of the other things and now we're in
a situation in northern ireland or
yester political arguments and
differences and problems with the
institutions but that violence that we
sought to stop and that he played such
an instrumental part in that has
succeeded
became becoming the first minister
jointly being awarded the nobel peace
prize back in 1998. what is his legacy
would you see say bertie home i think he
you know he he he got that peace prize
with john goomb
and
you know went to ultimately the house of
lords and you know got a lot of other
kudos as well but i think they the
reason is if you're voted down into a
sentence that he had the opportunity um
in the position he was that was leader
of the ulster union's party to take the
role of peace and give political um
political process and opportunity to to
strive and to survive or to to allow to
stand back walk away from the talks and
allow the um the violence continue and
he would in spite of all the opposition
he he took in my mind the right road but
i think the right road for the people in
northern ireland that of peace and that
was a brave and courageous move
and i think that is his legacy
and northern ireland assembly recall has
been postponed today as a mark of
respect for his passing i mean what do
you think he would want to happen about
the ongoing power showing impasse that
that's currently blighting the assembly
well he was very much against the the he
was for
brexit against the protocol so um but he
he certainly was for political progress
so i think he would like to see
that the institutions
would be back up and running and that we
would find a solution negotiated
solution to the protocol and he was a
good negotiator so and these things have
to be resolved uh and you know hopefully
with a bit of sense on all sides
we can see the protocol issue resolved
between the united kingdom and the eu
and then we'll be able to get on with
life in northern ireland in in the way
that we all want to see that happen